student loan debt in the u.s. is big
business but just how big is big 1.2
trillion dollars that's four times what
it was in 2003 which was 250 billion
dollars and it's higher than the credit
card debt of all Americans combined last
year the federal government made over
forty 1 billion dollars in interest and
payments from these loans that's almost
enough to pay for the entire budget of
the Department of Homeland Security and
it's more than the annual profit of
ExxonMobil it's also more than Apple
made last year thirty seven point five
billion dollars and almost twice as much
as Chevron twenty one point four billion
dollars even if you took the combined
income up for four largest US banks that
number would still not exceed the total
u.s. student loan debt what does this
mean for you in the US there's a one in
five chance someone in your household
will have student debt that's more than
double the share in 1989 odds are you'll
owe more than $26,000 but there's a 10
percent chance you'll owe more than 61
thousand dollars if you graduated in
2010 on our working there's a 38 percent
chance your job requires less than a
high school diploma and this isn't just
a problem for new grads 2.2 million
Americans who owe money on student loans
are over the age of 60